you're not saying no no don't feel like
that you know you're not a burden we
will look after you whatever it takes
suddenly you change it you say maybe
you're right maybe you are a burden what
does it do for suicide prevention in
mentally ill people so to change from
saying whatever happens we will always
support you to in certain circumstances
we will actually help to kill you that's
crazy that must be a hard practice to be
in no it's just the best work I'd ever
done in this section honored to be part
of somebody's uh doubts really weird
[Music]
Dr Alan weeb welcome to my podcast thank
you for having me
thank you very much for joining me
before we get started can you give me a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
um I have been a family doctor for many
many many years and uh I had a full
service Family Practice doing everything
from Cradle to grave and uh for a long
time and then I concentrated on women's
health uh which um primarily was
abortion and contraception and uh since
our law changed in 2016 I have been
providing medically assisting deaths
so now I don't do any family practice
anymore and I
um just do the Women's Health and
assisted dying
okay you said and I'm a professor of the
university and I uh lots of research
um had Publications and teaching and and
that sort of thing
okay great
um you said when the law changed in in
2016. so what was that law so this is
the medical assistance and dying law in
Canada and that came about because of a
constitutional court case uh the court
decided that Canadians had the
constitutional right
to have an assistived up and in the
particular situation of having a
Greedious and intermediable condition
that caused unbearable suffering
and they had to be voluntary
then that was the court decision and
then the law came in which added some
safeguards that there had to be two
clinicians that agreed that that
somebody was eligible under the law had
that there had to be
um you know a waiting period and and
a witness for the consent Etc
uh then that law was amended uh in 2021
from another court case which said that
uh some of the safeguards did not follow
the Constitution and were therefore
struck down and the main one was that
the natural death the reasonably
foreseeable now I know that your
audience are in different countries so
just want to compare a little bit in the
U.S 20 percent of Americans are live in
states where they do have assisted dying
as well uh all of those States except
Montana have the rule that you're
natural that that your expected death be
within six months and ours was that
their natural death must be reasonably
foreseeable
uh and then that was struck there uh so
that the idea that um uh you know
somebody who who could expect to suffer
unbearably for the next 30 Years
um also had the right to an assisted
death
uh in Australia most of the states have
assisted dying and they their laws uh
are
um either a six months or 12 months uh
so that the expected death must be
within six to 12 months
and in all cases uh the issue of an
assisted death means that a clinician a
doctor or an a nurse practitioner and
um prescribe a medication that would end
the death or
um actually against your medication
uh we have in addition to our laws we
have a number of regulations and
standards and guidelines that we have to
follow these are through our problems
through our
professional organizations uh by the
people who license us so we have
information is coming from every
direction and uh so in Canada it's rare
that anybody gets the medication uh to
drink and do it themselves
because our regulations are that we must
be there all right and that
as so and that I have to have the
um intravenous medication ready in case
something goes wrong so in Europe This
is called euthanasia when a doctor
actually
injects the medication uh actually gives
the medication to a patient but in
Canada we don't use the word euthanasia
except for involuntary like that's what
we use or our pets
um when nice them uh here we call an
assistant yeah
and uh in some places it's called
assistant suicide and especially in a
place like Switzerland or uh the U.S
where they are required to ingest and uh
or to do it themselves
and uh so that's that's sort of how the
terminology goes
okay so in Switzerland so you just said
they're required to do it themselves so
you don't have a doctor administering it
they have to administer it uh yes and so
um our one Clinic uses IVs but the but
the person must actually push the button
wow okay
allows the righty fluid to come through
um and another clinic uh generally gives
people something to drink
hmm hey guys if you enjoy a few glasses
of wine once a week or a drink at any
point in your life in any amount you
need to try the supplement I launched
after party it helps you break down a
sea towel to hide which is the toxin
that alcohol ethanol converts into in
your body when you drink that poisons
you and leads to alcohol damage the
supplement is made of dihydramy-racetin
which is a terrible name for a
supplement which is why we called it
after party which also works weekly on
Gaba so it can help with anxiety
following drinking as well if that's
something that bugs you obviously don't
abuse alcohol but if you're into
biohacking and you don't have a hangover
pill you're doing it wrong you could say
you're doing biohacking wrong if you
drink anything but hey Life Is Life
sometimes people want to have a few
drinks
smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off and
you can try it for 30 days completely
risk-free because we'll give you your
money back if you don't want it
obviously there's no point in getting
wasted so don't do that but there's also
no point in drinking any amount
without helping your body break down
acetaldehyde so try it out
smartdrugs.life code MP for 15 off I
hope you enjoy the rest of this episode
how does that work for people who have
you know end-of-life diseases that stop
them from moving exciting exactly that's
um and that's why
um most of uh
um Canada and and most of the Australian
states allow for intravenous if if
somebody has trouble
in the Benelux countries that's
Netherlands Belgium and Luxembourg
almost everybody uses IV for the same
reason they a Canadians do it's that
it's faster it works quickly double
paced back the uh and the doctors uh are
expected to be there
yeah that must be a hard uh practice to
be in no
well you know I've been a doctor for 47
years now and I've loved my career
um I delivered over a thousand babies
and I took care of families as I said
from Cradle to pray even that I love but
I can tell you that this is the best
work I've ever done
really it's not straight and why why is
that
why is that it is such an honor to be
part of somebody's uh death to
um we have to be able to offer them this
this control over the end of their lives
uh it's such a
um
such an ulnar tube to have these
conversations with people
um what I don't know why have you
decided to die now what makes your life
worth living what
um do you want to get done before you
die how would you like your dad's to
look and uh I'm you know I'm privileged
to be there for the last goodbyes
YouTube spouses you know and get it for
15 years I'm
um uh
as a as a doctor there were
um tones when I couldn't couldn't end
somebody's suffering
um whether I had to helplessly watch
somebody suffer uh at the end of late
you know we studied palliative care and
I did my best uh I got the
um people who knew more than I did to
help me but there was still so much
suffering at the end of life and
um now I can actually end the ShopRite
and it's just for people who want it I
mean I
um
we really work with people who are
asking for it and I asked at the very
last minute are you sure this is what
you want to do today now
and uh so yeah
yeah
um I can like I can see I didn't realize
so did Canada not have this option prior
to 2016 correct
okay okay I I had a grandmother who
passed away from Alzheimer's and it was
just
brutal it was just brutal and I had a
great uh great uncle who had a ALS
and again
brutal super traumatizing for everybody
around them and so I can definitely see
where this can stop a lot of suffering
that nobody wants to go through or bring
on their family
um what what's who's the average person
you think you see who asks for this we
know but we've got statistics you know
okay National statistics and I keep my
own as well
um so we know that the vast majority
have cancer and uh their uh the average
age of 70.
um so it's uh it's typically people who
are
white rich well-educated used to being
in charge of their lives you know we get
uh uh so many you know retired doctors
and lawyers and business people uh they
kind of yeah are used to yeah
um being in control and when they find
out that they've got their stage four
cancer or their Als in some countries
it's called what motor neurons disease
instead of ALS when they find out that
they've got that diagnosis and they are
I see what's coming up and you know they
they call them and uh and you know
that's been the most important change I
think for our country
is and that now when you get that I mean
we're all dying right 100 of us and when
you get that awful
diagnosis and it's happened since 2016
to three of my close friends where they
got the diagnosis stage four cancer it's
there's no more Treatment available
nothing can do
um they know what I made before they do
anything else they know that they have
made it available and so
um they called me up and ask about it
because they know that when I do and it
just gives them more peace going forward
I mean each of my friends went ahead and
and took treatments and
and took whatever
um is was offered one is has had her
made and the other two are still doing
cancer treatments and but uh they know
that they're going to die they're cancer
symptoms and they know that they've got
control like
um some of it but a lot but some control
and that's just made such a difference
you know now before you face this you
know you're going to have some control
over the end of your life
if you want
yeah yeah interesting okay
um
what about the scenario when people are
having mental illness and the mental
illness is painful enough yeah what
happens to those people exactly so uh
our mole currently
um
um excludes anybody for whom the soul
underlying medical condition is Middle
illness okay wow okay uh this happened
with the
um uh with the uh amendment in 2021 they
put in the Restriction they gave they
gave it a sunset clause which meant that
it expired in two years which was next
month but then I just gave an extension
from for a year uh okay in 2024 March 17
uh people will be eligible for a
psychiatric suffering when that is their
soul underlying medical condition is the
psychiatric condition
but we have lots of experience now with
concurrent disorders I mean lots of
people that both physical and mental
illness and when I uh first was dealing
with this
um you know I was bit of a struggle
because
in all my practice if somebody said they
wanted to die I would think oh they were
depressed
yeah and out now I was I was listening
to people who had perfectly logical
reasons to say I want to die
um because they had ALS and they had a
Line in the Sand I'm not going past this
line in in how much I'm willing to
degenerate and become dependent on
others and so I had to figure out okay
okay okay so what do we know about
depression and how it can interfere with
people's ability that think and and make
decisions and and of course I wasn't
alone and I had more of my colleagues
and and uh psychiatrists said to consult
and and so so seven years later I have
um it and you know 47 years of being a
doctor uh I had a lot of experience with
people who had the concurrent disorders
you know serious mental illness plus a
physical condition that would make them
eligible for an assisted death and in my
research
um
we are looking now at what's been
happening since 2021 when we could help
people with the chronic conditions the
ones where they still had a long a life
expectancy and expectation of suffering
for uh maybe a decade or more and uh so
um we have discovered in our research
that um a majority of these people have
serious measure illness now as you can
imagine if you are suffering unbearably
from some physical condition for decades
um would that make you
have mental distress yes yes definitely
so a lot of it is just secondary
um but there also was
um uh middle illness that's just
concurrent yeah and the more serious
ones you know so effective and bipolar
with psychosis and uh and um personality
disorders
um uh this is the severe ones uh and so
on so we have we have now had quite a
bit of experience with concurrent mental
disorders where people are suffering
terribly from a mental condition
um in addition to physical conditions
and so I I am facing 2024
um with the confidence that uh that we
can do our assessments well and
um help people after that time
it's
um
uh the assessments that we need to do
are first of all for capacity can this
person make this decision reasonably if
you're actively psychotic you can't I
mean
um uh but if you're delusional about
certain things you care like for example
I had a patient who was dying of a
really nasty bone cancer or in awful
pain now she was delusional she was
totally convinced the FBI were watching
her in that nursing home
um but she was not delusional about a
fact that she had pain caused by bone
cancer
uh she knew precisely so she did have
capacity to make the decision that she
um didn't want to suffer that pain
anymore and and the fact that
um she still believed that the FBI were
after her
um was wasn't
um interfering with her ability to make
that decision so even somebody who has
some delusions can make on medical
decisions it's more complicated to
figure it all out right but uh it's
possible and you know I mean uh I have a
family member with schizophrenia and
there are in the last 17 years since he
was diagnosed
um there were four occasions on which
his rights were taken away he was
hospitalized against his will and
treated against his will but all of the
rest of the time he has the same rights
as any other citizen he has he can
direct his own care he can do everything
and he does it always you know make wise
decisions that his parents agree with
what but
um he has true rights and that's uh also
what
what I um
realize when I'm talking to or my
patients who have concurrent disorders
okay okay that makes sense
um let me see I've got a list of
questions that I try to stick to
um okay yeah what are the steps patients
need to go through with a physician to
be allowed to get medically assisted and
what is it called in Canada medically
assisted death
um medical assistance and dying uh yeah
okay uh it's
um and even U.S medically benign which
is both the um the acronyms made for
both countries
uh so
um the uh first thing is a request and
uh we have in Canada we've got part um
the coordinating centers in every
province
uh and so you can go through your main
coordinating Center uh you look it up on
the internet and find it or you know
through your doctor or through
somebody you know and uh they make
coordinating office will then uh find
you a doctor or a nurse practitioner to
do the assessment
um someifying come referred from other
doctors just the way doctors refer to
each other yeah
knows who I am and refers their patient
to me and some just find me because I
have a website and
um you know want people to be able to
access this it's they don't know how
other other ways of doing it and so uh
each province has a request forms that
people tell in and these by law must be
witnessed by an independent person an
independent person means somebody who is
not
providing the need like I can't do it
yeah and who is not near will so ah okay
example my staff can do it because uh
they're not directly providing anything
uh for these patients and they aren't in
the patient's will
so uh there's sort of the request and
then
um two clinician assessments and these
assessments are they can be done by
video or I can do lots by Zoom uh or in
person and
um you know we have to make sure that
um they fit all the criteria so they
have to be able to make a military
request be capable of making sense make
it when you requests they have to have
previous and irremediable condition uh
that's causing invariable suffering and
and uh we have to decide whether their
natural death is reasonably foreseeable
in Canada because we have to um separate
them into track one to track two track
one has no wait list so these are our
cancer patients and
and job heart failure patients who have
a natural death that's reasonably
foreseeable they can choose you know
their date whenever they want uh anybody
whose natural death is not reasonably
foreseeable has a three month uh waiting
period and during that time when we must
make sure that they have explored
everything that that is available in
terms of dealing with symptoms
um generally
um that had their their condition for
for a decade or more and uh they uh have
explored everything but sometimes we can
figure out oh well there is a new
treatment and
um you know the last time you saw a
specialist in your area was four years
ago and it yeah it wasn't available then
so it's our job to figure that out uh to
see whether there's is something that
they've missed uh
um during that during that three months
period
okay that makes sense and is that do you
know if that's similar in the U.S and in
Switzerland and yeah so uh in the U.S
there's um most some of the states have
waiting periods but they're short then
they're like two weeks and and none of
them has uh forming illness out loud
it's it's all
um
they're they're expected death six
months or 12 months
and how long I mean it's so you probably
know this but how long has that I didn't
know that that was available because you
said it wasn't available in Canada
before 2016. so there have been states
in America that have had medically
assisted dying for illnesses that were
going to end lives for a while for 20
years
got their law over 20 years ago
um Washington state was next uh
California was the same time as we were
in 2016.
um so yeah be so the uh as I said 20 of
the population of the US are in states
where they uh do have right the right to
an assistant deck okay and was
Switzerland one of the first places to
have this because I'd heard of
Switzerland for a while
um uh what happened was all all the
countries most Western countries had a
law against suicide and where people
actually got to put jail if they'd fail
that's suicide account oh yeah and that
those laws were all rescinded you know a
long time ago and back in the 1940s when
Switzerland rescinded their suicide so
they no longer put people in jail they
failed their suicide attempt and then
they had
um in there it said that and uh anybody
who assisted a person to Suicide for
monetary gain
um was what but people who didn't we
were not and so it meant that anybody no
I didn't have to be a doctor
um could assist somebody to Suicide as
long as they weren't
um
um benefiting over their will or or
something like that right
and it took a while before there were
actually clinicians who were
providing this they also had do not
um have a residency requirement
um each of the American states and the
Australian States and in Canada have
residency requirements so we can't take
foreigners
but Switzerland doesn't so they're the
one and twice but people uh can travel
team to get an assisted death
hmm okay that must have been why I'd
heard of that because people could
travel there interesting okay are are
doctors our medical associations
do they ever recommend assisted death or
does this have to be brought up by the
patient
uh that's all the same thing uh so the
important thing is um what we call a
serious Elders conversation so when
somebody has about
a fatal illness and uh I thinking doctor
is is having that conversation uh you
know this is what's happening this year
heart failure has gone to the point
where
um we can only just manage it and your
life expectancy is now short
uh then the important thing is to make
sure they know their options and that
would be you know what kind of um
palliative share how can we make you
more comfortable
um available in our area is there a
hospice uh residential hospice for
example Home Care Hospice where and
people will come into your home and help
take care of you as you die
um and you know what is available for
you and at that point
um they should know that there is
medically assisted death available
because that's part of how you would
choose you might say
um okay well I don't want to burden my
family when I'm no longer strong enough
to you know make it to the toilet and so
on so uh I would go into a residential
hospice at that point rather than expect
my family to be taken care of me
and uh and then you know
you have to actually know that that one
particular residential hospice won't
allow me and this is the dying there and
you need to choose one over the other so
you need to know these things you need
to know what's available and how best
friend the end of your life of whether
you want a natural death or an assisted
death so that's that's really part of
informed consent for the whole end of
life care and
in an ideal situation that's part of the
serious illness conversation
and by somebody
uh and you know it's not at the time of
diagnosis usually I told you that my
friends uh who got their horrible
diagnoses in the last seven years that
was one of their first thoughts was uh I
figure this made suck out
um make sure I have an exit if I know
you know if I get to a point where I
can't Astound it anymore but it's not a
necessarily that you say to somebody I'm
sorry uh this your tests show that the
cancer has spread the chemos aren't
working anymore
and we need to talk about
um providing the best possible comfort
for you
um as you base the end of your life and
that might be the right day maybe it'll
be a few weeks later
you know but yeah
yeah that's probably too much
information on that day I would say
do you think there are any cases in
which assisted death should not be given
as an option
um do you mean Diagnostics or yeah
diagnoses no says no I don't make that a
diagnosis itself
um uh takes all your rights away because
that's what you're talking about right
so uh but as I said I mean just because
you have a diagnosis of schizophrenia it
does not mean you have all your rights
taken away for the rest of your life no
you have rights taken away sometimes
when you're acutely psychotic you cannot
make this decisions for yourself
uh and a legal a year bright so I'm
taking away from you but once the acute
psychosis is over then
um you like marani's stepson and you
have total right over your own body and
more
um do you have any
comments for people who might be
skeptical about this procedure
or who might not understand it or
something
yeah yeah it just
um uh if this is a basic right that
people should have and luckily do in
many places to help control their own
dying
and uh and so it's important that we
have the safeguards in our loan and in
our you know standards and guidelines
and so on to make sure that
um that vulnerable people are not
pressured
but uh we have those and I'm really
confident that's
um everywhere I've uh
investigated to know about uh like the
European countries and Australia and U.S
Canada
um people who take this very seriously
and would do their assessments carefully
and are following the safeguards in our
law
okay Dr Ellen Webb thank you very much
for coming on if people you said you had
a website could you tell everybody what
the website is if people want to find
out more
Hemlock Aid
Hemlock Aid okay well thank you very
much for coming on that was very
informative this episode is brought to
you by nordvpn I went back to visit
family in Canada and it's still crazy
there I just turned my dad onto nordvpn
keeping your information away from
prying eyes including the government
particularly if you're in Canada is a
silly thing to not do in this day and
age it's way easier than it was 10 years
ago and you can basically turn nordvpn
on to run in the background and forget
it's there nordvpn has award-winning
online security so you can be confident
knowing that you won't be exposed to any
prying internet eyes or have your
personal information leaked to people
who might use it against you just go to
nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp for 61 off
their Premium plan and their free
anti-malware feature as well as
nordvpn's 30-day money-back guarantee
Mark Pickering welcome to my podcast
thank you very much great to be here
before we jump in can you give a brief
background about who you are are and
what it is you do great so my name is Dr
Mark Pickering I'm a GP family
practitioner by background most of the
clinical work I do is in prisons and
other secure environments and I lead the
Christian medical Fellowship in the UK
so that's an organization of just under
5 000 doctors nurses midwives and
students so we try to help them live out
their faith as Christians in whatever
that means and part of what we do is
looking at public policy and bioethics
issues so things at the beginning and
end of life are very important and
that's so assisted dying is really
important because there's a lot of
pressure to change the law all around
the British Isles okay okay well let's
delve into that a little bit
um what what is medically assisted dying
it really depends who you ask
um because many people who talk about it
and they are not always clear on their
definitions and when you ask the public
what they think they're often not clear
either
um to say that you're assisting someone
who's dying that implies that they're
actually dying so that the classic
situation would be somebody who's
terminally ill maybe they've got cancer
or motor neuron disease and they're
approaching the end stage of their life
and you might say they're in the dying
process or the final weeks of life and
then they might be suffering with pain
or shortness of breath or other symptoms
that are difficult to control and they
might ask a doctor to give them
medication or prescribed medication for
them to take so that they can die in a
more peaceful fashion than they might do
otherwise
um but there's so many things wrapped up
in that that need unpacking that often
don't get unpacked so like I say to call
it assisted dying
um many people particularly in Canada
for instance who access made Medical Aid
and dying they're not actually dying
they might be chronically ill they might
be disabled in some places it might be
um a young baby who's very disabled it
might be somebody with a mental disorder
and so you may have a degree of
suffering but they may not be dying and
so that causes a lot of confusion
because often if you ask people in the
public what do you understand by
assisted dying they might think that
that is the care that you get when you
go into a hospice for palliative care
um for someone who is dying you are
resisting them by treating their
symptoms
that would be a valid
um way to talk but it's not what most
people understand or very often there
are complicated ethical decisions
towards the end of life for instance if
you make it do not resuscitate decision
um when someone is
um perhaps approaching the end of their
life and you think okay there's no point
in doing cardiopulmonary resuscitation
CPR if there aren't long stop because
it's not going to work that may be very
appropriate just to say we're going to
make that decision that that would not
be appropriate or you might say you know
you're having chemotherapy for your
cancer but it's clearly not working so
we think we should stop that treatment
treatment is futile it's not doing you
any good
um many people think that that is
assisted dying because then you're
stopping a treatment which they may sees
as keeping them alive so there's a whole
range of different things and it's
incredibly important to get your
definitions right especially when they
change across different countries and
jurisdictions and conversations
currently what's legal in in the UK yeah
so in the UK or in the British Isles
you've got a number of different
jurisdictions so there's England and
Wales there's Scotland there's Jersey
there's the Isle of men and then there's
the Republic of Ireland and all of those
different jurisdictions have got
campaigns to change the law in different
ways so it's a it's illegal to end the
life of a patient so as a doctor you
can't do something that will actively
end their life and if they say to you
please give me a medication so that I
can end my life you can't do that so
it's illegal to encourage or assist a
suicide it's not illegal to commit
suicide it used to be but um you know
many people who try to take their own
lives often have mental health
challenges and so if you try to take
your own life because of a mental health
problem and you didn't succeed and then
you ended up in hospital you know what's
the point in making you feel worse by
then Prospect executing you for
something but you still can't encourage
or assist a suicide and you can't
actually do what we call euthanasia by a
doctor or clinician giving a drug to you
to end your life
but you can do all of those other things
around the end of life you can make good
decisions about is this particular
procedure or treatment that you have
been having is that actually benefiting
you or do you want to decide yourself to
stop it or do we decide as a clinical
team that it's not beneficing you and
various things around that so we call
that withholding and withdrawing of
treatment and that can be perfectly
appropriate so this is completely
different than what's happening in
Canada now yes absolutely so my
understanding of the law in Canada is
that it changed in I think 2016
um where euthanasia first became legal
or Medical Aid in dying is this called
the medical assistance to dying sorry
um and when the Canadian law first
changed well you can have either
euthanasia or assisted suicide
euthanasia is basically when the
clinician or someone else gives the
medication to the person usually through
injection to end their life whereas
assisted suicide is where the clinician
prescribes it and then provides it to
the the person but then the person
drinks it or take the tablets themselves
so it's it's a question of who does the
Final Act and I understand that the vast
vast majority in Canada are euthanasia
where the clinician will end the life of
the patient
usually that's with their Express
request and permission but in some
situations particularly in countries
like Belgium and Holland sometimes it
happens without the patient making a
request
but in Canada where it started in 2016
um there was a clause that said the
person's death had to be reasonably
foreseeable so in many ways that's like
terminal illness
um how we would say many of the proposed
laws in the British Isles often put a a
stop on it to say you've got to be
within six months of death from a
terminal illness it's very hard to
actually guess how long someone has left
and how many months they would live
otherwise
um but that's basically what many laws
say so that originally was there in the
Canadian law
but because there was no time put it
then actually that got quite elastic and
so some people whose deaths from their
condition may have taken five or ten
years were being seen as eligible for
made and therefore um in 2019 there was
a court case in Quebec where two
disabled people said look this isn't
fair we're not chronically or we're not
terminally ill our deaths are not
reasonably foreseeable but we are
suffering we want to have access to made
as well so they were granted that access
and then that led to a change in in the
law across Canada so that now your death
does not have to be reasonably
foreseeable
um for many reasons of suffering or
chronic illness you can request that
um and now there's a proposal to extend
it further to purely mental conditions I
know that's been paused but certainly
that's still it in the plans for Canada
as well so it really has changed very
rapidly over just uh six or seven years
in Canada okay and and what are the
downsides if the point of this is to
relieve people's suffering yeah so the
downsides are largely
um though there's several of those so a
person's suffering may be temporary
so if someone has cancer they have pain
they're in a lot of pain and for
instance maybe their family physician is
treating them their GP
um and they may not be able to relieve
that pain that person may think I can't
live like this I want to have
um euthanasia
um but if they had access to a
palliative care specialist who is an
expert in dealing with this kind of
symptom control they may be able to get
much better pain relief symptom control
and feel a lot better
um there may be other reasons why the
distress may be short-lived it may be
that actually the suffering that they're
going through is largely psychological
and emotional more about the meaning of
what's happening to them it may be a
spiritual cause what will happen to me
after death there are so many different
reasons for that and somebody may not
have had good psychiatric care they may
not have had good palliative care or
symptom control
and and so there's all of these
different reasons there and if we ask if
we change the law to make it first of
all legal then people may access that
who didn't necessarily need to have that
because like I said about in Canada the
the law is expanded quite rapidly the
numbers have grown rapidly the societal
expectations have changed quite rapidly
so whereas it may have been
um legalized to begin with so that just
a small
cases would be accessible to euthanasia
then that often changes greatly
sometimes we like we like to think about
it say if you compare it with speed
limits or on on the road
um most countries have speed limits and
that's generally sensible it keeps
people safe and yet we've all been in
situations where we think I wish there
wasn't a speed limit here we might be
late for work we might be late for the
airport we might be late for the cinema
we might somebody might be ill we might
be having to get them to the hospital
and so it's you can understand the
argument of saying I wish that if I you
know I would like to have the choice not
to have a speed limit you know if I feel
that I need to go as fast as I want to
then you know I should be able to do
that and you understand that but then
when you start trying to frame and lure
around that to say well like you can
only
you know speed 20 miles an hour above
the speed limit you can only do it if
the if the flight that you're trying to
get to is really important you can only
do it if it's a medical emergency you
know all of these things get really
complicated but then what you actually
do is you change society so that people
just think actually speed limits are a
bad thing we should be able to go as
fast as we can and then what becomes my
choice then becomes a duty that Society
has to provide for me and then actually
you change the expectations and the
implications for others you get more
road traffic accidents more deaths of
innocent people and that's quite a good
illustration of what can happen because
we now see in many countries where the
law has been changed then investment in
palliative care often doesn't keep Pace
with other countries because people
think well why should we spend all this
time trying to control your symptoms
let's just give you euthanasia why don't
you opt for that if you're an elderly
person with chronic illnesses and
infirmities you may be using up the
money that you'd like to give to your
children and grandchildren to buy a
house with and you might be using it up
in Social care costs and so then the
expectation comes on you aren't you
being a bit selfish by staying alive and
eating up that money you know yes you
may be suffering a bit but actually it's
hard for your family to care for you
surely you should be asking for that and
even if people are not saying that to
you then there's there's definitely an
expectation that comes on to people
because when we when people talk about
safeguards with changing the law they'll
often say oh you know our law has got
lots of safeguards around it so that
nobody will request it who doesn't
really want it
that sounds fine when you're looking to
change the law but what's my what seems
like a safeguard on one side of the law
change when you look at it from the
other side after you've changed the
little then people start talking about
barriers to patient access so most
countries will say will only do it for
people who are terminally ill and that
sounds great but then like in Canada you
do that you change people's expectations
and then some people a few people who
may be disabled or chronically ill will
say well why don't we have access to
that you know we're suffering for a long
time too don't you care about us and
then suddenly you have to widen it
because you're saying well this isn't
fair we have to provide this for
everyone as soon as you say that
medically assisted death medically
provided death is something that's good
that you should be able to provide then
on what grounds can you limit it and not
give it to other people
so is your opinion that it's just a
slippery slope and we shouldn't go in
that direction at all or should it be
available for people stay with motor
neuron disease that are definitely
suffering and definitely going to die
relatively soon
yeah I think those are exactly the kind
of questions to ask so that the term
slippery slope some people love it some
people hate it
um
you know it can give you the idea that
like if you're on skis if you push off
the top of the slope you'll go straight
the way down to the bottom it's cut it's
really hard to stop that's not always a
great analogy but what we often prefer
to talk about is incremental extension
that once you've crossed that first
barrier
you say Okay terminal illness great then
what about people with chronic illness
and disability then you say only people
over 18 but what if you're 16 and mature
or uh you know then you say only with
mental capacity well what if you've got
early onset dementia you we know that
you don't want to
you know Advance dementia so even though
you don't quite qualify maybe we should
extend it that way so
um it's very hard just to keep a law at
one place and never to change it
virtually every jurisdiction that's
changed the law has extended it further
in different ways
yeah that makes sense I think one of the
things I'm concerned at least about in
Canada is
um and I used to be in chronic pain from
arthritis and I had a number of
surgeries for that and getting access to
pain medication there was a three-month
waiting period
when I was 17. three months when you're
in chronic pain severe chronic pain is a
very very long time and so if the access
to ending things if it doesn't seem like
you have some sort of future is easier
than the access to pain medication and
the Health Care system in Canada too is
like even though they think it's world
class it is not a world-class Health
Care system so that's concerning
um but I can also see where people are
coming from having watched people die of
dementia slowly and painfully I I can
see do you know do you know what's
happened in Switzerland because
Switzerland's had more access to
medically assisted death for a while
right and even people from out of
Switzerland can go and travel there for
it do you know what the stats look like
there like is it more old people yeah so
Switzerland is is an unusual place they
have had
um provision for assisted dying I think
since the 1930s and so some people in
the UK who want to access that but they
can't do it in the UK they will
sometimes travel to Switzerland and
usually that's assisted suicide where
the patient drinks the medication or
takes the tablets sometimes it can be
euthanasia they're quite Broad in their
um in the categories that they will
allow and many of the providers in
Switzerland will only provide it to
Swiss citizens but there are a couple of
organizations who will allow people from
other countries to go there and some
people look at that and say you know
it's just been part of Swiss culture for
years you know we shouldn't worry about
it you know they haven't started killing
everybody it hasn't really extended
massively and I think there is a certain
argument for that but then you look at
another country like Canada and you
think why has it gone so far so fast so
quickly
um and and really changing the culture
very fast and people will sometimes
point to Oregon in the USA and say well
they've had it since 1997 the law hasn't
changed much you know that's the kind of
law we want but you can't promise that
when you ask for Oregon that you won't
get Canada and you can't say well I like
Switzerland you might get Belgium
because
um attitudes to so many things are
different in different cultures and
things will have different effects you
know Switzerland is a very wealthy
country
um people have a very high standard
living and there's I haven't looked at
the stats in great detail there but I
think you'll you'll have a lot less
social deprivation
and you'll have a lot less people who
can't get access to the health care that
they need whereas very sadly we're
hearing in Canada some horrific stories
of people who you know they just want
good housing they just want good medical
care or social care and actually they've
got a constitutional right to be killed
by the state they can access made very
quickly
but they can't access good housing like
you said about the
um about the pain medication you may not
be able to get the health care that will
actually reduce your suffering and so
that's a terrible situation to be in uh
you know we may say that doesn't happen
very often but it is happening in some
situations and if people say if if we
say well you've got a right to access
euthanasia but you don't have a right to
access prompt social and medical care
that's setting up a whole problem for us
that I I think we should be incredibly
worried about and especially when you've
got custom living crisis you've got um a
mental health crisis particularly after
covid there's so many factors that
should lead us to be very careful indeed
can you go into more detail about what's
going on in Belgium you said you can be
euthanized against your will in some
cases
yeah so in Belgium and Holland have both
had
um euthanasia for some years uh Holland
came first and then Belgium I think was
about 20 years ago and they have seen
that study expansion of the criteria so
that to begin with in Belgium again it
was just for terminal ill people and now
it's expanded gradually people have
become more comfortable with it and then
people are
less willing to actually go through the
criteria
um properly so that doctors become less
careful about checking whether someone
actually fulfills the criteria if you go
to one doctor and they say you don't
fulfill them then you can go to another
doctor who says you do and we have what
you call Doctor shopping when people
will go around and find a doctor that
they know is positive about euthanasia
ask them and then of course they'll help
help with them
um so
most in most situations euthanasia would
be what you call voluntary when someone
say it goes through different
um uh different uh procedures
um questions and and screening things
where you you'd make sure that they
really want to have the euthanasi that
they've actually looked at their options
maybe experienced palliative care or
psychiatric care
um they've maybe seen two doctors you
see you can do that quite well but in
many situations you don't
um and that would be voluntary
euthanasia if you know for certain that
the patient has requested it
you can't have on the other set on the
other hand non-voluntary euthanasia when
you just don't ask them if for instance
you had a patient who had Advanced
dementia they may have said something in
the past you know if I ever get like
this I don't want to live you know I
would want to have euthanasia if I ever
got severe dementia
the trouble is when people actually get
to that point you don't know if their
opinion then is the same as it would
have been when they were healthy many
people look differently on life when
they actually are disabled or
um suffering in some ways because the
life that they didn't expect to have is
still better than no life at all
but if someone's in advanced Dimension
you think out of compassion they would
want us to end their life you can't get
consent from them but you might decide
that that's the way to do it
or you may just think actually it's too
much difficulty to fill out the forms
and we're seeing some really really bad
cases in Belgium I think when people are
just not going through the procedures
because it's become more normal
and so some elderly people I understand
will go into Hospital in Belgium
actually trying to be really clear do
not give me euthanasia because they're
worried that actually somebody might
make that decision for them and then
you've got involuntary euthanasia when
the patient may not even want it but you
decided it's the right thing for them
now thankfully there are very few cases
like that but there was a a case
recently I forget whether it was Holland
or Belgium but a patient had said
previously that they would like
euthanasia if they go if their dementia
got to a certain stage it did progress
then they said to them would you like to
have it they said no oh that's a bit odd
you know some days they'd say yes some
days they say no of course it's dementia
it's hard to judge their mental capacity
it may fluctuate and so then the the
family and the clinical team decided
okay we go we're going to go ahead with
it because that's what they said before
we'll give them some medication to make
them drowsy then we'll give them further
medication to end their life the patient
was actually you know refusing fighting
it off and it and actually then someone
held them down while the doctor
euthanized them because they believe
that that's what the patient would have
wanted and there was a criminal
investigation there nobody was charged
um and you know it's very rare in these
situations even when people don't follow
the rules it's very rare that anyone
gets into trouble have you heard in
Canada about organ donation and and uh
euthanasia what's going on with that
yeah so my understanding is that uh
quite a number of organs for transplant
are now coming from patients with
euthanasia and clearly if you have a
medically controlled euthanasia you can
have everything set up to go the pity it
may take place within a hospital you
could have an e-statistan transplant
surgeons on hand so that the quality of
the organs that you get is
coming is actually very good you can
have it very quickly between euthanasia
and then organ harvesting now um and I
understand that organs coming from the
euthanasia cases that the majority of
those in the world are coming from
Canada
now you can look at that and you say
well you know isn't that a good thing
because you know this patient wants to
die but they want to contribute to help
someone else live isn't that altruistic
and yes it might be but then goodness
what what sort of
um conflict is that putting someone in
to say well actually
you know maybe I don't want to live or
maybe maybe I'm a burden on my family
maybe I should ask for euthanasia oh and
actually I could then give my organs to
someone else who may benefit from them
so there's an emotional pressure
um that really shouldn't be there
um you know we we was quite reasonably
be um very upset to think that executed
prisoners in China might be
um having their organs removed without
their consent but actually if it's
coming from euthanasia patients who
might be influenced by that decision
then that could be a problem indeed it
doesn't have to be a massive problem but
you can see there's a real danger of
that complicating the decision that the
patient makes
that could easily complicate it if
you're suffering from a mental disorder
that's making you feel like a burden
like you said so you already feel like a
burden you've had this mental disorder
for 20 years you're not getting the
proper care and hey you can go out stop
your suffering and save some people
yeah absolutely a mental mental illness
is a massive problem
within the within this situation so I
mentioned before that the when the
Canadian law changed a year or two ago
to
um to remove that reasonably foreseeable
death Criterion then they put a clause
in to say that in I think 2023s are
coming up this year then it would then
open out to people who purely have
mental health conditions as well now
there's been a lot of
um
a lot of resistance to that more
recently I understand and I think that's
been paused but I don't think there's
been any
um intention to to remove this and I I
listened to a Canadian documentary
recently by I think it's a senator who
was a psychiatrist who was the one who
pushed for that crew as to be
um inserted and it was really quite
frightening to hear him saying you know
it's terribly it's terribly stigmatizing
to people with mental mental illness
they should have access to what everyone
else does you know if it's good enough
for other people mentally ill people
people should be able to get it as well
and there's a terrifying cold logic to
that as well but then you think goodness
if you're only problem is a severe
depression
or schizophrenia or a personality
disorder
if you are suffering mentally then
you know how will that affect your
decision-making power you know how do we
know that some more time on treatment or
some different treatment might actually
make things a lot better
and and I look after a lot of people
with schizophrenia personality disorders
in my clinical work and many of them
have chronic suicidal thinking so an
emotionally unstable personality
disorder that often goes along with
self-harm that could be present for 10
20 30 40 years and that person will
every day feel like killing themselves
they may sometimes self harm they may
sometimes attempt suicide but that
doesn't go away there's no pill that you
can give to necessarily remove that with
with Psychotherapy you may be able to
help it significantly help them to
control it but once you say that a
person in that situation should be
eligible to say hey that's enough I you
know I want to have euthanasia as well
okay but you know how much are you um
opening that up to other people who's
suffering maybe short-lived they may
simply not have had good
um psychiatric care there may be so much
else they can do and then when people
feel a burden
um which is a massive reason why people
opt for euthanasia then you're not
saying no and I don't feel like that you
know you're not a burden we will look
after you whatever it takes suddenly you
change it you say maybe you're right
maybe you are a burden maybe this would
be a good thing that's how you feel we
agree with you
what does it do for suicide prevention
in mentally ill people or mentally
suffering people
to to change from saying whatever
happens we will always support you to in
certain circumstances we will actually
help to kill you that's crazy
yeah so yeah it it's crazy
what are you working on specifically to
kind of push back against this well I
think one of the things in the British
Isles um is is really helping to show
people The Logical consequences of what
they are proposing so here in the
British Isles or in the UK that the main
campaigning organization is called
dignity and dying and they're very
focused on their campaign goals they say
we only want um assisted suicide not
euthanasia and we only want it for
adults who are mentally competent so
they they can make that decision
genuinely that they're terminally ill
and that they have less than six months
to live
and that's very tight campaign they've
changed those campaign goals over the
years because they've realized they've
had many decades of being unsuccessful
in changing a little and so now they're
saying okay we're going to focus it down
on this there's much more chance of
getting a law passed through Parliament
and there is because when you put it
that way you say look this is just a
small change just for a small number of
people at the end of their life you know
why wouldn't you force them to suffer
but the trouble is there there are other
organizations who don't think they go
far enough here in the UK there's
another group called my death my
decision that looks to Canadian
euthanasia and says that's great that's
what we want to have in the UK so
then so dignity dying I think are being
very naive or possibly
um possibly something worse than that
when they say don't worry you know we'll
if we get Outlaw then it won't extend
further because you know there are
people already campaigning to to push
you further
um you know we look and see in Canada
how how fast things have gone and why
you know why would we think that things
wouldn't go like that you know we're a
similar country in many ways in terms of
our culture and I think it's foolish to
just believe that that wouldn't happen
here even if it didn't go half as far or
half as fast that would really worry me
um and also when we're looking at um how
the law can change in a country
um it's really important to see well in
the different jurisdictions around you
what are the what are the rules that
they're trying to to put across so in
Jersey for instance they did What's
called the citizens jury which is when
you ask people from the population what
they think should happen and
the the general public are generally
more liberal or more lacks in the rules
that they would have than politicians
are because
politicians at least have the
professional responsibility to think
what about the unintended consequences
whereas most individual people just
think well I don't want that for me or
for my loved one and it it's not their
job to think well what could go wrong
with this whereas for politician you
hope it is so dignity and dying were
campaigning heavily in Jersey to change
the little and it's quite possible it
may change the law now we're looking for
we're waiting for some draft uh a draft
Bill to their Parliament to look at but
the citizens jury said we don't want
just one assisted suicide we want
euthanasia as well we don't just want it
for terminal illness we wanted for
chronic illness and disability and some
of the people in there in there said we
want it for those under 18 those uh with
dementia that sort of thing not all of
those got through but it's a
significantly wider low than dignity and
dying actually we're asking for so we
often say be careful what you wish for
okay Mark I think that answers all my
questions
um I didn't know that about Belgium so
that's freaky it is
yeah yeah do you want to talk just a
little bit about how Faith impacts on
that
sure sure go ahead so I mean it's one of
the common responses that people who are
campaigning to change a law will say to
someone like me to say oh it's just
because you're religious yeah you know
yeah you believe in the sanctity of life
I don't believe in that so you know your
reasons don't matter
um but then on the other hand you have
lots of religious people who say well
you know Jesus taught us compassion you
know therefore we should relieve
suffering so the former Archbishop of
Canterbury in the UK George Carey who is
now in the House of Lords he's a
supporter of assisted dying but really
interestingly he campaigns for dignity
and dying
who have that very tightly focused
campaign but the actual situations the
cases that changed his mind were people
who had chronic disability and chronic
illness they were not terminally ill so
he even admits that the people that
changed his mind the situations are not
the ones that he's campaigning for so
you know of course he's gonna if he gets
his his
um law that he wants to tightly
conscripted law he's still going to want
to have compassion on those other people
who are going further so you see that
little change has got the seeds of its
own expansion within it but it's not
about whether you have a faith it's
about how you apply that and for many
people you know the way I look at it is
it's about
making sure they're vulnerable people
are not put at risk by law but um
that the autonomy of one group of people
doesn't impact on the safety of others
and these are just generic things you
don't have to have a faith to understand
that there are plenty of humanists and
atheists who opposed to it as well so I
think we must be really careful before
writing off somebody just because they
have you know One Faith or another view
or the wrong kind of you and very often
the the reasons behind
um opposition to law change they are the
same across all faiths and not
okay I'm actually glad you brought that
up because yesterday I was like okay
Mark Pickering
um and then you're you're part of it and
I'm a Christian but I didn't want the
Christian perspective on this because I
was like so so many people will write
that off right it's like but so I'm very
glad you covered that
um
and I think everything you spoke about
makes sense so thank you again is there
anywhere I can lead people to online
where they can learn more about this
yeah absolutely So within the UK we've
got care not killing.org.uk so that's an
organization that I speak on behalf of
uh for clinicians and healthcare workers
there's a a linked group called our duty
of care.org.uk
and then for those working in Parliament
uh dying well dot Co dot UK which is um
a group of parliamentarians in in
Westminster particularly who are opposed
to changing the law so all of those have
got great
um uh great information on the links to
other places I'd really
um encourage people to go and have a
look at those
okay thank you very much for joining us
okay leave you're very welcome thank you